tourné monté et cuir vous êtes bien à la
borne célèbre repère de potiers depuis
le xiième siècle et depuis cette année
le village est aussi un peu connue pour
la nouvelle marianne
nous allons voir ce qu'en pensent les
habitants bonjour comment trouvez vous
la nouvelle marianne moi je trouve
qu'elle est magnifique
allez une chevelure vraiment qu'un
profil très agréable par les traits
féminins
elle voit peut-être chez pas l'avenir
elle va vous connaissez l'artiste je
sais que les dix sept artistes c'est
isolde digue ans elle a grandi dans ce
village comme le montre cette photo
d'elle enfant aux côtés de sa mère la
célèbre céramiste janet steadman comme
chaque été
celle qui vit aujourd'hui à abidjan
retourne dans le cher pour se ressourcer
trouver une inspiration à l'image de sa
marianne engagée
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est en fait sur
ce travail autour de la marianne c'était
vraiment de sortir de l'esthétisation
féminine et de lui faire porter un
message un message fort qui soit voilà
cette femme fière volontaire avec un
regard qui porte loin qui portent vers
l'avenir
un projet qui a séduit l'elysée sur une
centaine de visuels huit ont été
retenues par 500 pupille de la nation en
décembre 2017
emmanuel macron choisi la marianne
engagée avant de dévoiler son visage à
périgueux à la mi juillet en présence de
son auteur
n'oubliez jamais que ça a commencé ici
avec vous et avec votre engagement
citoyen un visage minérale perles encre
de chine qui a su convaincre le
président isolde 10 gants le sait son
succès lui vient de sa terre natale
une terre de potiers ce que je suis
aujourd'hui c'est parce que j'ai grandi
dans cette dans ce village qui était un
village de potiers d'artistes et parents
aussi été potiers céramistes et avait
vraiment un engagement créatif très
important et je pense que
mon parcours est très liée à ce que j'ai
pu vivre à la borne ne pas oublier d'où
il vient c'est la devise d'isolde 10
gants la même que son père qui a sculpté
ce totem emblématique de la borne avec
sa marianne déjà imprimé sur plus de 300
millions de timbres la street artist est
déjà sûr de passer à la postérité